je m'appelle nicolas dolto bonjour à
tous aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
l'audace être audacieux c'est quelque
chose que je connais bien
grâce à mon métier parce que je suis
coach en séduction depuis six ans et
depuis six ans j'ai aidé des milliers
d'hommes des milliers de femmes à
s'aventurer au delà de leur zone de
confort pour aller provoquer des
rencontres et à avoir du succès pour
choisir choisir pas subir pas sortir
avec quelqu'un parce que cette personne
était assise à côté de moi en terminale
pourquoi l'audace d'abord parce que
l'audace c'est une qualité rare c'est
une qualité rare et qui va changer votre
vie aussi bien sur le plan affectif 1 ça
c'est mon métier que sur le plan
professionnel
c'est une qualité rare et ça nous
concerne tous hommes femmes jeunes vieux
et ce qui est génial avec l'audace c'est
que c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
irréversible
quand on a été timide toute sa vie on
peut commencer à oser et votre vie va
changer maintenant pourquoi l'audace
parce que vous manqué d'audace
la société ne vous apprends pas être
audacieux l'école ne vous apprends pas
être audacieux l'école vous apprend à
être moyen à rester dans les rangs il
faut passer son baccalauréat il faut
faire ses études
ça vous connaît il faut essayer de
choper une mention avoir un stage
envoyer son cv et ses terres etc
on vous prépare pas à monter votre boîte
avant vos 23 ans qui a élevé sa qui a
monté sa boîte avant ses 23 ans ici 1 1
elle s'est passé ça s'est passé je
devrais voir la moitié des mains de se
lever dans l'amphithéâtre en séduction
c'est pareil il faut développer tout un
tas de qualités pour plaire au sexe
opposé
mais surtout il faut surtout pas aborder
c'est super mal vue il faut surtout pas
faire preuve d'audace à ses quelque
chose donc qui est assez mal vu et moi
j'aimerais changer ça et la dernière
raison c'est que le faire preuve
d'audace
c'est quelque chose qui va vous rendre
profondément heureux j'en suis la preuve
toutes les choses dont je suis fier
aujourd'hui qui me rendent heureux eh
ben je les dois à l'audace et avant de
vous donner cinq conseils qui vont vous
aider à être plus audacieux dans
différents aspects de votre vie je vous
parle est un petit peu de moi pour vous
dire d'où je viens j'étais un garçon
très timide
ok l'audace pour moi quand j'avais 16-17
c'était de lever la main quand j'étais
en cours ok c'était de prendre un max
chicken le prendre un big mac quand
j'allais au mac devront et j'étais très
timide donc je m'intéressais plus tôt à
la lecture plutôt aux jeux vidéo en
ligne
j'avais pas beaucoup d'amis et puis je
me suis mis à faire du sport par défi
beaucoup de sport et ça a complètement
changé ma façon de vivre c'est à dire
que j'ai appris que je pouvais prendre
du plaisir à m'aventurer en dehors de ma
zone de confort à aller dans l'inconfort
j'ai appris a échoué ça c'est hyper
important qui s'est déjà planté parmi
vous mais vraiment c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal on est quasiment à
50% mais c'est tout le monde devrait
lever la main sur ce truc là donc j'ai
appris à échouer j'ai appris à réfléchir
non pas en termes d'obstacles objections
par exemple tiens il ya cette fille et
cette jolie fille au téléphone a
maintenant elle au téléphone je peux pas
aller lui parler mais en terme de
challenge de prise de risque d'objectifs
j'ai appris qu'il était plus bénéfique
pour moi sur le plan humain de sortir de
ma zone de confort donc d'aller dans
l'inconfort là où ça fait mal que de
rester dans ma zone de confort et quand
vous avez compris ça vous commencez à
comprendre plein de choses vous
commencez à comprendre pourquoi des mecs
conduit succès continuent leurs
activités alors qu'ils sont vieux je
suis sûr que vous êtes déjà demandé
pourquoi bill gates il continue pourquoi
les rolling stones il continue pourquoi
je sais pas charles aznavour et cetera
fabrice luchini tous des gens qui sont
qui sont déjà âgés continuent leurs
activités parce que sans ça ils sont
morts c'est une drogue
c'est une drogue et pas nocive et pour
eux le fait de s'arrêter d'aller boire
des mojitos sur le bord d'une piscine à
miami ça les intéresse pas c'est la mort
pour eux ça ok donc il faut comprendre
ça le plaisir vient de du fait de se
dépasser et donc d'être audacieux pour
se dépasser
donc voilà le sport m'a appris à
préparer à devenir audacieux et j'ai vu
le résultat peu de temps après avec les
femmes
j'ai fait beaucoup de rencontres je me
suis pris beaucoup de râteaux aussi au
final on se souvient que des rencontres
donc là j'ai pas mal de souvenirs en
fait à raconter mes enfants et
petits-enfants et donc j'ai passé mon
diplôme j'ai fait mes études des études
d'informatique et comme tout le monde
à paris le matin je prenais le métro
pour aller travailler dans un grand
cabinet de consulting est ce un métier
qui me plaisait pas et la première prise
de risque dans ma vie j'ai pris goût de
d'un an et demi deux ans c'était de
quitter mon job
mon job me plaisait pas j'ai quitté mon
job tous mes collègues étaient là mais
tu es fou des fous pour eux je perdais
dabul ainsi un job qui était bien payé
promesse d'avenir j'ai quitté ce taf
deuxième moment j'ai fait preuve
d'audace c'est quelques mois plus tard
quand j'ai monté ma boîte de coaching en
séduction avec un ami et le troisième
moment et ça c'est hyper important pour
ceux qui veulent monter leur boîte
prochainement et je suis sûr qu'il y en
a que ça titille un petit peu déjà c'est
que quand on est monté notre boîte pour
se faire connaître
on a fait le choix de films et des
rencontres en caméra cachée de les
mettre sur youtube
là ça peut paraître assez banal
aujourd'hui il ya peut-être même
certains d'entre vous qui ont vu mes
vidéos mais à l'époque il faut se dire
que youtube ce n'était pas un média qui
était très exploité il n'y avait pas des
vidéos qu'ils aient des millions de vues
en une journée et on était le 1er les
premiers à le faire aujourd'hui des gens
qui veulent travailler dans mon domaine
ils font exactement la même chose mais à
l'époque nous personne le faisais
c'était vraiment une prise de risque on
était tellement pas sûr que ça allait
fonctionner qu'on a acheté le micro et
la caméra la plus pourrie possible pour
mettre le moins d'argent possible au cas
où on en voudrait pas les usages
derrière donc voilà voilà pourquoi je
suis là devant vous aujourd'hui
et voilà comment l'audace a changé ma
vie alors le premier conseil que je vais
vous donner la première leçon si je puis
dire c'est de comprendre que le temps
c'est l'ennemi de l'audace ok l'audace
c'est quelque chose on est dans l'action
on est dans le maintenant on est dans le
tout de suite il faut agir maintenant
à partir du moment où vous savez que
vous devez agir ou alors que vous avez
envie d'agir la pression commence à
monter et il ya que deux moyens
d'échapper à cette pression soit vous
renoncez c'est ce que font la plupart
des gens soit vous passez à l'action
donc le temps est l'ennemi de l'audace
et ailleurs c'est un truc on remarque
quand on va à la piscine
moi je quand j'étais ado je surveillais
la piscine municipale de mon bled et
quand tu vois les gens remonter sur le
pont joueurs et commençaient à hésiter
c'est très très très très rare de voir
quelqu'un hésité pendant dix minutes et
prendre la décision de sauter donc la
pression c'est quelque chose qui va vous
tuer il va falloir apprendre à enrayer
ce processus
il va falloir ac et votre cerveau
pour éviter d'être confronté à la
pression mais des fois vous serez
confronté à la pression comme ici par
exemple avant de parler on va ressentir
une pression mais le reste du temps il
faut faire en sorte de passer à côté et
je vais vous donner un exemple qui va
vous parler s'agit d'aborder hockey de
provoquer une rencontre
ça va parler aux mecs déjà parce que
alors il faut savoir une chose provoquer
une rencontre en soi c'est déjà très
audacieux a aujourd'hui tout le monde
utilise les applications thunder happen
les sites de rencontres a d'hôtes
mythique etc etc
mais ça c'est fait je veux dire c'est
tout le monde fait ça un levé la main
ceux qui se sont déjà essayés à ses
applications
ouais je suis sûr qu'un acquis menthe je
suis sûr qu'il y en a actuellement deux
parmi vous c'est pas possible
toi t'as essayé toi maintenant tout le
monde fait ça et le simple fait d'abord
dépassé déjà c'est faire preuve d'audace
il faut savoir que j'ai connu je veux
arriver à paris kinder existait pas les
applications existaient pas donc j'ai vu
l'avant j'ai vu là prêt et je me
souviens que ce n'est pas du tout la
même mayonnaise
il ya quelques années auparavant il ya
beaucoup plus de couple qui se forme et
en soirée les gens s'embrasser les gens
échanger leurs coordonnées quitté le bar
où le club ensemble et aujourd'hui tout
le monde a tendance à rester dans son
coin et je vois les gens beaucoup plus
flipper dès qu'il ya quelqu'un à qui
attire l'attention qui va commencer à
faire des rencontres à parler fort et
c'est les mecs commencer un petit peu
flipper à se dire ouh là là je vais
devoir m'écarter d'ici parce que il va
venir croquer dans mon sandwich
donc voilà affaire abordée c'est déjà
faire preuve d'audace
alors le conseil en or que je vais vous
donner pour pour oser aborder je voulais
être un petit peu en situation imaginez
que vous allez à la salle de sport
hockey et là vous décidez d'aller faire
du footing et sur le tapis de course
juste à côté de vous voyez une fille
sublime
elle est en train de faire son petit
footing aussi en leggings et là vous
avez vraiment envie de de l'aborder et
donc là vous commencez à la reluquer
vous la regardez vous cogiter vouloir
lui qu'est la voie que vous la regardez
se dit [ __ ] ce mec est un pervers je
vais appeler la sécu c'est généralement
c'est ce qui se passe la fille vous
prend pour un taré avant même que vous
ouvriez la bouche est en fait la
meilleure chose à faire pour justement
éviter la pression parce que vous allez
plus vous allez cogiter - vous allez
passer à l'action ce qu'il faut faire
c'est dès que vous arrivez sur le tapis
par mme voulu adresser la parole disent
un truc est évident dit quelque chose de
complètement con dit lui bonjour si vous
avez un peu d'imagination fait une vanne
proposer 8 sur la course 10 puis ça te
dérange pas que je met ici mais à partir
du moment où la glace est brisée
croyez moi ça va être beaucoup plus
simple après et ça c'est un conseil qui
s'applique absolument partout à la
machine à café dans votre nouveau staff
un meeting n'importe vous pouvez
appliquer ce conseil dès que vous voulez
parler par exemple à quelqu'un qui vous
impressionne c'est quelque chose
également qui est valable il ya un autre
moment vous pouvez faire preuve d'audace
lors d'une rencontre est tout simplement
et c'est ma petite amie qui m'a fait
qu'il m'a fait la remarque en fait c'est
le simple fait de passer un coup de fil
aujourd'hui les mecs ont peur de passer
un coup de fil je le vois avec mes
clients c'est quelque chose qui défilent
aujourd'hui je le redis passer un coup
de fil pour lui propose et ont
rendez-vous dans ils veulent absolument
envoyer un texto le simple fait de
passer un coup de fil
ça a marqué ma petite amie et ça m'a
permis de me démarquer des autres hommes
qui la courtisent est très certainement
à cette époque là alors qu'est ce qu'il
en est des filles parce que croyez moi
pour les filles les filles aussi elle
souffre du fait de ne pas avoir assez
d'opportunités amoureuse ainsi je
regarde mes copines 90% d'entre elles
sont célibataires et pourtant c'est des
bombes
un des neuf en or l on tchatche elles
sont sexy elles sont indépendantes elles
sont drôles
célibataire depuis des mois bordel
comment ça se fait comment ça se fait il
faut que les femmes apprennent à faire
des rencontres et un conseil que je vais
vous donner les filles parce que c'est
pas facile d'avoir des cantons une fille
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est
encore moins naturel que pour les mecs
sains pour les mecs c'est attendu pour
les filles c'est moins attendu est
souvent quand vous le faites
malheureusement vous le faites de
manière très maladroite
un conseil que je vous donne c'est
d'initier la conversation avec un homme
en lui demandant son aide
pourquoi parce que les hommes aiment
penser on va leur laisser croire qu'ils
sont indispensables
c'est un truc qui leur plaît ils adorent
[ __ ] génial et alors comment vous
allez faire tout simplement demander
votre chemin dans un quartier que vous
connaissez par coeur
l'autre jour il ya une fille qui m'a
demandé de l'aider à ouvrir le la boxe
de son scooter
un enfant de 10 ans aurait pu le faire
génial comme approche
si vous êtes en soirée demandez lui de
garder votre siège demandez lui de tenir
votre vrai cependant que vous allez
chercher votre verre remercier le
chaleureusement après la merci ça fait
vraiment plaisir au fait je m'appelle
nicole enchanté hockey quel mec va dire
non en fait à une demande d aide c'est
un excellent moyen de briser la glace
quand vous êtes une fille ait voulu
laisser ensuite l'opportunité de
continuer la discussion
donc ça c'était mon premier conseil la
deuxième chose dont je vais vous parler
c'est que pour être audacieux il faut
enfreindre les règles alors que je sois
bien clair je vous dis pas de détourner
de l'argent je m'en veux que vous
finissiez en tôle dans une carrière
d'homme politique non il faut enfreindre
les règles dans le sens je vais me
démarquer de manière positive
qui parmi vous a déjà répondu à postuler
une offre d'emploi lever la main ok ça
fait pas mal de monde vous êtes qui a
envoyé un cv qui a renvoyé déjà plus de
10 cv
voilà il est là le problème tout le
monde fait la même chose tout le monde
agit de la même manière et tous les cv
parce que croyez moi mais j'étais dans
une position je recrutais des gens tous
les cv disent la même chose vous pouvez
pas dépendre de votre cv si vous voulez
décrocher le job de vos rêves
ok parce qu'une société ça ne mange pas
un cv sans embauche une personne avec
des qualités et l'audace c'est une
qualité qui va vous permettre de vous
propulser devant tous les autres jeux
vous raconter une anecdote pour que vous
compreniez un petit peu comment faire
parce que c'est pas très concret tout ça
très récemment j'ai embauché une
personne pour faire du montage vidéo ont
produit beaucoup de vidéos donc on a
besoin de quelqu'un pour découper
sous-titré flouté etc et on a mis une
offre d'emploi sur internet est
automatiquement au bout de 48 heures
notre boîte mail elle était saturé on
avait peut-être 400 500 offres on n'a
pas le temps donné de lire 500 cv de
donner 500 entretiens
comment comment faire en fait on a tout
simplement sélectionné on n'a passé que
deux entretiens on a essayé
les deux personnes qui ont fait preuve
d'audace qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ces
deux types au lieu d'envoyer leur cv
leur lettre de motivation comme tout le
monde ils ont directement
ils ont eu quelques heures pour le faire
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'ils
ont fait en très peu de temps ils ont
envoyé une vidéo et c'est ça qui était
génial parce que du coup nous on n'a pas
du tout regardé les scellés on n'a pas
lu un seul
on a regardé les devises et les deux
vidéos on a fait passer deux entretiens
et ce qui était génial dans cet écueil
en plus douteuse de s'auto de s'auto
interviewé pour faire passer leurs
entretiens d'embauché de se démarquer en
plus de ça il nous montrait par la même
occasion qu'ils étaient fit et pour le
travail qu'on attendait il était il
avait les qualités nécessaires etc ça à
faire preuve d'audace hockey et
aujourd'hui tout le monde envoie son cv
par par mail par internet qui a pensé à
l'envoyer au format papier
ah voilà génial prenez prenez exemple
sur sur l format papier format papier
prouver le nom de la personne qui
s'occupe du recrutement et envoyez lui
le cv va se retrouver avec 5 cv
directement sur le bureau
alors que dans la boîte mail il ya
peut-être dix mille enfin dix mille non
j'exagère un petit peu il ya peut-être
1000 ou 2000 c'est les uns répondre à
une offre d'emploi en envoyant son cv
c'est un peu comme participé à une
partie de pêche à la ligne dans un étang
où il ya 10000 canne à pêche et trois
poissons
ok et si on veut le job de nos rêves il
va falloir apprendre à se démarquer et à
enfreindre les règles le troisième
conseil que je vous donnais c'est que
pour faire preuve d'audace
ça commence ici ça commence dans la tête
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que l'audace
était de l'action ces deux l'immédiat
mais ça se passe aussi là où il faut
s'imaginer audacieux il faut aller voir
au delà c'est à dire que pour devenir
gros vous devez vous imaginez gros c'est
assez marrant parce que si on demande à
des surprend un panel de personnes et
qu'on leur demande quelles sont vos
prétentions salariales
la réponse type des gens c'est prendre
leur salaire et d'ajouter 10 % personne
ne répond un million de millions 1
milliard ok tout les gens voient petit
se limitent le même se limite même se
brident parce que il vise un niveau
qu'ils imaginent atteignable moi ce que
je vous demande si vous voulez réussir
dans la vie c'est d'aller viser au delà
voulait devenir gros penser gros comment
on devient milliardaire
comment devient millionnaire en faire
plus simple
oh mon dieu un millionnaire on vient pas
millionnaire part excédant on vient pas
millionnaire en demandant un salaire de
2000 au nom on devient millionnaire en
voulons être milliardaire
voyez ce que je veux dire oasis tout le
monde connaît le groupe de rock oasis
s'avoue pas ok ok ou des chante pas
aussi bien que oasis
quand ils ont démarré il disait dans
leurs premières interviews et cela vous
pouvez le vérifier on est le plus grand
groupe de rock de tous les temps
ils sont peut-être pas devenu le plus
grand groupe de rock de tous les temps
ou alors c'est discutable pour certains
peut-être mais le fait d'avoir de
l'audace et d'annoncés il faut pas avoir
peur de faire ça parce qu'il ya déjà la
moitié des gens qui vont vous croire et
ça c'est déjà énorme
le quatrième conseil que je veux vous
donner c'est d'oser demander
il faut oser demander c'est quelque
chose qu'on fait pas mais c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut faire systématiquement
on va jamais vous en vouloir
ça va vous servir lorsque vous allez
avoir besoin de négocier vous allez
avoir besoin de négocier à différents
moments clés dans votre vie et français
sont très mauvais pour négocier c'est
pas un truc qu'on nous apprend c'est
pour ça que quand on va à l'étranger
dans des pays où les gens savent
négocier
généralement on est les premiers à se
faire plumer vous allez je sais pas en
thaïlande vous allez au maroc des pays
où les gens sont très forts à la négoce
les français se font littéralement mais
voler quoi alors il faut comprendre une
chose
avant ça il faut comprendre que un objet
une chose à un prix variable
si je prends mon costume par exemple et
un prix variable j'ai acheté un certain
prix maintenant si je voulais le
revendre je ferai mon annonce peut-être
j'irai sur un site internet pour faire
une annonce sur le revendre je fixerai
un prix légèrement moins cher que ce que
j'ai acheté il est encore en bon état
je mettrai 200 euros peut-être mais il
faut savoir que ce prix les variables si
ce costume je le vend à penelope cruz
je suis prêt à baisser mon prix à 10
euros 0 même j'en ai peut-être même des
maîtres qui seraient prêts à glisser un
petit billet de 200 euros dans la poche
parce qu'ils vont utiliser ce costume
comme moyen pour entrer en contact avec
vous voyez que le costume peut avoir
différentes valeurs et vous allez avoir
besoin de demander de négocier au moment
vous allez être embauché on va vous
demander quels sont vos prétentions
salariales
au moment d'acquérir un appartement
exemple très concret puisque moi j'ai
devenu propriétaire il ya
il ya deux ans maintenant et j'ai
économisé depuis peut-être mes 18 ans
pour pouvoir vivre chez moi et mon
appartement je les payais 200000 euros
ça peut être vous paraître énorme mais
je vis à paris
deux cent mille euros mais appartement
il était affiché à 235 mille euros sur
la petite affiche de l' agence
immobilière pourquoi je lui à 200000
parce que je vais demander à 195 donc
demandé et j'ai économisé 35000 euros
35000 euros avec ça j'ai des potes ils
font le tour du monde puis fois donc osé
demander et le dernier conseil que je
vais vous donner alors on s'éloigne un
petit peu d'audace mais je voulais
rester sur cette idée de 2,2 d'investir
cette idée de gagner de l'argent il faut
savoir investir de manière audacieuse de
manière encore une fois différente on
veut pas faire comme tout le monde et il
faut savoir qu'en france on est un pays
où on valorise énormément ce qu'on
possède
si je vous dis par exemple si je vous
dis car vous allez vous acheter un
ordinateur flambant neuf
1200 euros ça choque personne c'est le
prix pas vrai ok j'en ai besoin pour
travailler maintenant si je vous dis
c'est 1200 euros vous allez les utiliser
pour aller au restaurant
là vous allez plus voir ça comme une
perte pas vrai c'est pas la même chose
au moins l'âge et l'ordinateur âge lège
le tout je peux m'en servir le
restaurant sais c'est quoi c'est rien
mais sachez une chose
à partir du moment où vous mettez le
doigt sur le clavier de l'ordinateur
commence à perdre de la valeur
c'est la même chose avec une voiture
c'est pire encore avec une voiture sauf
que le restaurant il va vous permettre
de récupérer votre mise au centuple
parce que si vous utilisez alors 1200
euros ça fait 100 euros par mois
si vous utilisez ces 100 euros par mois
pour inviter à déjeuner à boire des
coups à dîner des personnes qui ont de
l'importance qu'ils peuvent être
influente pour vous ces personnes là ils
vont vous renvoyer l'ascenseur à un
moment donné donc il faut investir en
priorité sur les gens importants
investissez sur les gens importants ok
et si vous n'avez personne proche de
vous qui est important qui a deux qui
vous avez envie de vous rapprocher
personnes invitées investissez en
priorité sur l'action parce que l'action
va vous faire rencontrer d'autres
personnes
j'ai lu un article autre jour sur
internet
et vous pouvez lire aussi c'est assez
amusant les vins chose que les gens les
10 choses que les gens regrette le plus
sur leur lit de mort et c'est
intéressant de voir que dans les trois
quatre cinq première chose c'est que des
choses qui sont en rapport avec le
bassin j'aurais dû faire plus j'aurai du
moins me soucier de ce que ce que
pensent les gens
j'aurais dû moins de se soucier de ce
que la société attend des noix etc etc
mais la société n'attend rien de vous ça
vous d'avoir de l'audace et ce qui est
amusant c'est de constater que dans
toutes ces choses là en fait il n'ya pas
un seul
j'ai regretté de ne pas avoir acheté le
dernier mac intosh le dernier air apple
ou le dernière ceci cela là je fais du
plâtre placement de produits pour apple
mais voyez les gens regrettent de ne pas
avoir fait assez preuve d'audace
voilà et pour terminer je dirai que là
j'ai pas mal parlé de séduction de
carrière mais c'est pas les choses les
plus importantes dans la vie
moi si les choses les plus importantes
pour moi au delà ça même si c'est la
réussite me rend fier des choses les
plus importantes c'est de passer du bon
temps
eh bien vous savez quoi l'audace ça va
vous servir à ça aussi
merci